and it's straight down past the hotel
registration
oh you know where it is
if you want to be governor of the state
you have to
be governor of all the people right
andy nicki this is peter smith
hello good
hi
if i wanted an easy summer and a run for
re-election i need your help
okay thank you we are being told that we
have to choose between whether working
people will be able to work whether it
be an economy in this state whether
people be able to afford to live here
who have to work for a living and
whether or not we can have the kind of
environment
on the grounds right now uh jeff may be
on the grounds we have one person he had
buttons in the ground he's getting
vision signatures right this is a very
scattered failure
okay
it gets a little tiring though and then
we're hanging in there how you doing
people here you want another button
you're socialized
we'll be voting for you thanks very much
how would you like one of these good all
right thank you buddy
where are you guys from
connecticut connecticut all right
i'm sorry that's all right we're from
we're from rottweil there you go
[Music]
[Music]
i thought you'd appreciate meeting lady
wilder who was a state representative
from orange county in the 30s are you
really
hey joy did a great deal to him
well you must have been one of the first
women there i think so yeah
do you remember
the woman from orange
um
she was the first woman legislator i
forgot her name right now
edna beer yes did you remember her oh
yeah
has anybody ever asked you about those
days have you ever done any taping and
no taping no you should yeah yeah could
you ever do that certainly sure because
uh she's uh she's history right
was it hard when you were first there oh
no i loved it every minute of it did
they uh
did you get a lot of attention because
you weren't one of the first women i i
don't know
yeah just part of the game
yeah were what did you do were your town
clerk at one time or oh i was a teacher
a teacher for 30 years 30 years yeah
that's wonderful how are you doing now
oh good yeah i'm surviving
[Music]
but you're in good shape you know you're
getting out you're doing oh yes my son
keeps me moving that's okay yes doesn't
let me give up on anything
i say oh
i don't believe i feel like going to
project today come on mother
that's the spirit yeah